13 weeks in
minus one game that gets played later
tonight but we will not delay the awards
for the ravens and the cowboys mds as i
said earlier we'll just assume no one
from the ravens the cowboys will do
anything award worthy and will trudge on
through without them so the four
categories as always offensive play of
the week defensive play of the week
rookie of the week coach of the week
we'll get it rolling with mds and the
offensive player of the week
well i've got darren waller the tight
end for the raiders who had an
outstanding game against the jets
catching 13 passes for 200 yards and two
touchdowns but i also want to point out
that on that incredible touchdown pass
to win the game where the judge shocked
everyone with that all-out glitch waller
stayed in and picked up the blitzer who
would have been right in derek carr's
face if waller hadn't made that block so
the guy's the raiders leading receiver
for the day but also a tremendous blitz
pickup on the biggest play of the day he
just had a great game he's playing great
football this year
he is mds and before i get to mine i'm
going to make note that we didn't forget
baker mayfield yes he had a great game
in the first half and anytime you're
throwing autogram's name in there it's a
great half we are we i had him on our
review as the best player in that game
and our review got thrown out so just a
note that we didn't forget baker
mayfield he just got thrown out in our
review and i'm going to pick devonta
adams because he leads the league in
yards per game of course he missed a
couple games earlier this season but
102.9 had just been amazing seven
consecutive games with the touchdown
10 catches 121 yards and two touchdowns
in the win
against the eagles the other day and
caught aaron rodgers 400th career
touchdown pass and you know i think the
receiver position is going to be really
hard to decide who the all pro receivers
are you only get to pick two of them but
i think we've got to put his name right
in there as one of those top two
receivers
yeah you know it's aaron rodgers and
it's devante adams aaron jones has good
performances from time to time he's not
consistently dominant there isn't a
whole lot of help in the passing game
for aaron rodgers beyond devante adams
if he stays healthy that team can go
extremely far and adams has been special
for me it's josh allen from the monday
night game josh allen was spectacular
last night when i spoke to him the prior
week after they beat the chargers i
asked him about the upcoming slate of
prime time games they have three in four
weeks
is there any element of we're anxious to
show the world what we can do and he
said there isn't the way he played last
night tells me there is this was an
opportunity for the bills for the first
time in a long time to win on monday
night football and they were great the
offense was unstoppable and when you
have against that 49ers defense because
they don't have the pass rush they had
last year
if you can't put heat on josh allen
those defensive backs can't cover good
receivers they just can't all due
respect to jason verrette and richard
sherman they can't do it they cannot do
it verret was in a cat and mouse thing
with stefan diggs last night and diggs
was the cat and diggs constantly won and
sherman i frankly i'm not i i don't get
it at this point because i don't really
see him do much of anything when the
play is on he stands in one spot he
moves a few steps he points at someone
else if the coverage gets blown and
that's pretty much it all due respect
all right let's go with defensive
players of the week for week 13 mbs who
you got
i got justin houston in the colts who
had three sacks on sunday one of which
forced the fumble another recorded the
fourth safety of his nfl career which
ties the all-time record he believes he
ought to have the all-time record all to
himself because he had another play that
he thinks he should have been credited
with the safety it was officially ruled
a team safety by the offense he thinks
he should have five career safeties
whatever he has four official career
safeties and he is playing very good
football i think he's one of the biggest
reasons that that colts defense is going
to make them tough to beat in the
playoffs
mds i'm going with the other guy who had
three sacks and that's kyle van noy and
he was miked up for the game and before
the game he said i woke up feeling
dangerous i'm going to get me a three
piece today and he got him a three piece
he had three sacks initially it was
ruled two and a half he had to split the
sack and before the game was over they
had changed that to a full sack for kyle
van noy but he had eight tackles three
sacks five tackles for loss one pass
breakup and you see the reason that
brian flores wanted to bring him in from
new england because he has been the guy
six game six sacks now for the season
four of them have come in the last two
weeks his career high was last season
was 6.5
i woke up feeling dangerous baker
mayfield finds another path into the
awards even though he didn't actually
make it into the awards this week that
was his great quote from a couple of
years ago his rookie season with the
cleveland browns
mine tyrant matthew for a couple of
reasons first of all he had two
interceptions against the denver broncos
and he sealed the team's fate denver's
fate that is on the drive that happened
with the broncos down only six points
but also tyron matthew made it clear
last week when he's done playing he's
coming to work with us so
you know this is just advanced employee
relations all right tyron we can't wait
to get you here but the way you're
playing i have a feeling it's going to
be a while he's been the heart and soul
of that defense ever since he arrived it
was a great move by the chiefs to get
him last year he's paying off dividends
over and over again and it's helped that
team become a complete team not just an
offense that is susceptible to being
outscored they do give up their share of
points but they clamped down the other
night and got the victory thanks to the
two interceptions all right it's rookie
the week time mds who you got
i got tate crowder of the giants he's a
rookie seventh round draft pick he's
making a big impact he led the team with
six solo tackles in a very good
defensive performance against the
seahawks on sunday and you know that
giant's defense has a lot of young
unheralded late round picks who aren't
playing like young unheralded late round
picks
obviously it helps that they're in the
nfc east in another division they
wouldn't be playoff contenders but they
are playoff contenders and i don't know
that that an opposing offense wants to
face that defense in january and the
scenario that really fascinates me is
the idea that tom brady could end up on
the road against a giants team that has
given him trouble in the postseason a
couple times i think that defense would
give tom brady everything that he could
handle i think that's something we
really need to keep an eye out for
because with players like tay crowder
this giant's defense is only getting
better as the season goes on
no question about that mds and i'm going
with the defensive player too and that's
cameron dantzler we all want to talk
about the vikings first round pick jessa
jefferson who's really stood out but
cameron denzler's done the same thing on
the other side of the ball of course he
had the covet case earlier this year but
the third round pick really has made up
for the losses they had at that position
in the off season been a very consistent
guy had his first career pick and he
also forced a fumble and the fumble came
on the only completion that he gave up
all day seven times he was targeted gave
up one completion for four yards and
forced a fumble by chris connolly at the
end of that so he had four tackles
interception force fumble and recovered
fumble and just was outstanding for the
vikings on sunday
they definitely need that on that side
of the ball with so much upheaval at the
cornerback position you mentioned their
first round pick justin jefferson that's
my guy i didn't have a dramatically huge
eye-popping day but it was consistent it
was solid it's what he tends to do week
in and week out he's got over a thousand
yards in just 12 games only the fourth
nfl rookie to ever do that and his first
two games were kind of in nothing they
weren't working him into the offense yet
it has proven the vikings right in the
trade that sent stefan diggs to the
buffalo bills and i think it's fitting
that justin jefferson wears number 18.
that was the number randy moss initially
wore when he came to the vikings before
he switched to 84 back in 1998. all
right coach of the week time mds who do
you have
i have daryl bevel who has said he views
his situation as the lions interim head
coach as a five-game audition to become
the head coach now i suspect lions
ownership probably wants to make a more
significant change and not just move on
to matt patricia's offensive coordinator
but i liked the way bevel had the lions
playing on sunday it would be easy for a
team in that situation to pack it in
after falling behind early instead the
lions played very spirited football in
the second half came back and won daryl
devil deserves a lot of credit for that
we all thought washington didn't feel
the steelers were going to lose we
certainly didn't think washington was
going to be the team to do it ron revere
fired after a five and second seven
record last season he's five and seven
this season and being talked about for
coach of the year what a turnaround for
ron rivera right team right coach right
time for ron rivera
definitely comeback player of the year
and alex smith baby coach of the year in
ron rivera i'm going to go to cleveland
since you snubbed baker mayfield shireen
we'll give kevin stefanski the coach of
the week award from my perspective look
that win over the titans signature
victory one of the most important wins
the browns have had in a very very long
time to go into tennessee and prove that
they
could not only just compete with a great
team but blow a great team off the field
they have a burst of confidence and
zefanski told me after the game this is
december football the guys are working
harder and better and smarter and they
know what the stakes are week in and
week out and they are right on the brink
of making it to the postseason for the
first time in 18 years
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports